there's some bad news
out of universities in washington dc
one university in particular
georgetown law school
there's a big dustup at georgetown law
school
the dust up is this ilia shapiro who is
a libertarian lecturer at the georgetown
law school and he's the head of the
center for the constitution ilia shapiro
said that biden is is doing the wrong
thing by limiting his selection for the
supreme court to a black woman
by excluding effectively 94 of of
americans from consideration
elia shapiro suggested that an an indian
woman
who is a judge b
biden's pick he said that she is the
best candidate
and every other candidate would be a
lesser candidate
and the way he phrased it i guess was a
little inaudible but he said it should
be this woman but joe biden because he's
playing this identity politics thing is
going to instead nominate a lesser
nominee who is a black woman
and this has been
i think willfully misconstrued by
leftists to sound as though elia shapiro
is saying that black women as a category
are lesser than some other group which
obviously is nobody it's just literally
not what he's saying and it's quite
clearly in context not not the point
that he's making so what happens in this
case
students are disagreeing with a
professor
whether because they've misunderstood
what he's saying
because these students are
they're not the creme de la creme as we
will come to see
or because
they
are willfully trying to misunderstand
what he's saying so that they can get
rid of him what what do you do
in a good flourishing society you would
just argue your point
calmly rationally say that this
professor is wrong and he he should face
x y and z consequences but because we're
not living in a reasonable time right
now
the students are instead
huffing and puffing and throwing a
temper tantrum and dragging the dean of
the law school into a struggle session
where they say they need a place to cry
a place to cry seriously georgetown law
students this is a good law school and
these students are saying we you we
don't have enough places to cry on
campus
and and and the craziest part about the
whole story is
the dean is indulging them
it's really hard to walk out caring
it is really really hard to walk out of
class or leaving in tears
and you should always have a place on
campus where you can go and feel like
you're not then also under people's eyes
and observation maybe you don't want to
answer a question of what's going on or
what's wrong
and if you're finding that you're not
getting the person you want to talk to
or not getting a space that you need
reach out to me anytime anytime
so we will find you space and we will
find you the rights
these students do not need places to cry
these students
need
to shut up
get themselves together
and then behave like adults behave like
like future lawyers there is no crying
in the law there's no crying in baseball
there's no crying in the law
they do need comfort these students but
they don't need a a box of tissues for
comfort they need comfort like we see on
the bio tapestry bio tapestry very
famous work of western art where there
is an image of of a bishop holding a
club swinging the club at his soldiers
and it says here bishop odo
wielding a club comforts the boys i'm
not saying we literally need to start
clubbing students who cry a lot but i
but i am saying that we need comfort in
that
sense meaning to give strength to
toughen them up saying get back in the
fight fellas
no way sorry you can't behave like a
six-year-old if you want to be a a
lawyer if you if you want to be at a
prestigious law school if these students
can't hear an opinion that they disagree
with without bursting into tears they
should be expelled because they're not
they're not up to snuff they're not
competent
they're not educated and they might
maybe they're intelligent enough maybe
not they're certainly not educated
enough to be in law school and so they
need to leave they need to go away from
law school for a little while and grow
up
and and then maybe they can be at the
level where they can attend a
prestigious law school but right now
they're not there if they're bursting
into tears because some libertarian
makes a perfectly fine point
they're not there
this the crazy part
is not even the students i feel bad for
these students they're not well prepared
they're not well educated they shouldn't
be at georgetown law school
it's the administrators that i really
blame at one point one of these students
you gotta you gotta almost give her
credit
she
brought up out of nowhere she said that
there is uh people talk about
reparations for black people in america
and so she wants reparations to begin
right now by having the dean bring her
some snacks
and the dean
acquiesces
coming back to the reparation thing
because like this is this is great but
we have to do so much work to catch up
for all this stuff that we missed all
i'm saying is i don't know if it's a
couple dinners or lunches or something
but
that would help us because we like we
can't i can't go home for lunch now
because i need to study i have to i have
to make up for this class that i lost so
it's little things like that it doesn't
have to be something that takes a year
to figure out it's like we know our
black students or whatever group is
hurting and we're going to give them
things today whether it's snacks whether
it's counseling whether it's whatever
but the part of that trust is to see an
immediate reaction to what we are saying
baboo will be great
we have food on the way
i'm good
it's that's the most pathetic part at
the end
i hope this girl is half joking i think
she's half joking but she's half not
joking too she's saying we need snacks i
missed class and i got to make up that
class now because i cried because i
couldn't stand it i wasn't able to make
it through class because i'm obviously
not prepared for this law school
and so i had to go cry
and so i need i need snacks and i need
you to bring me some dinner and i need
you to bring us dinner
on the basis of our race the white kids
don't need dinner the asian kids don't
need dinner but the black kids need
dinner she's saying we don't we're not
capable of getting our own dinner and
our own snacks i don't think that's true
i'd bet that girl can probably get her
own snacks in fact i bet that girl
doesn't even really need to cry
i bet she is wielding vulnerability as a
mask for her own viciousness
and her own desire to to
beat her political opponents into
submission that's what i think this is
really i don't think i think these are
crocodile tears of very vicious people
who have been very badly educated
but
and i bet she can get her own snacks and
i bet she can get her own dinner she
seems perfectly capable she's capable of
bringing the dean of the law school to
his knees i think she can probably go
get a bag of potato chips
the craziest part about it
is that the dean of the law school says
of course snacks are already on the way
we're already doing it we already agree
with you
we already agree with your
deeply offensive
premises and we've already done it
fellas i have the perfect gift for that
lovely lady in your life this
valentine's day that would be knives
kamikoto taps into more than 800 years
of traditional techniques from honshu
japan kamikoto also uses steel sourced
only from mills in japan and each blade
is crafted using techniques that have
been honed and perfected by generations
of knife smiths each knife comes in a
beautiful heavy duty ash wood box makes
sure that the knife is stored safely
also makes kamikodo a great gift i
really love these knives sweet little
elisa really loves these knives too when
you can go and present
a really high quality sort of
kitchen utensil like this it can make a
really really wonderful gift i love it
elisa loves it you're going to love it
too kamikodo is currently having a
massive valentine's day sale and on top
of that sale you can get an additional
50 bucks off any purchase you make with
discount code knowles click the link
below or go to kamikoto.com knowles and
use promo code noles to save an extra 50
bucks today
glad you like that show
ring the bell
ring it you got to ring the bell
ll ring my bell and then if you're still
not getting notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you listen to your audio
podcasts leave a five star review type
in the michael knowles show subscribe
good to go we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you